my question is I understand if I take
mobile phone and I say this I make a
call I don't believe you make it and I
make it go okay this is evidence that
the call is actually make at least
that's good because yeah it's rare to
have people like you in the park because
a lot of people are stubborn and they
want to have a nice conversation with
you I haven't had this in a long time so
I'm quite excited today I'm gonna prove
to you that God Almighty existence yeah
and how I'm gonna do that is I'm going
to do it in a few ways
now firstly I'm a Muslim we don't
believe God is a man we don't believe
there's one so this is not a matter of I
don't know it was it you was the chance
that I'm a lamppost and you will be
melted in the lamppost you can be I'm
talking about me myself okay so
therefore we acknowledge using our
culture's our rationality the basic
logic that I'm a human being and I can't
be a lamppost so therefore it's very
relevant knowledge approving me because
you see nothing you know that but
I don't know
you know yes right now is there anybody
anybody I don't wanna be biased is there
a chance is there a chance for me to
turn into a potato
No yeah I don't know right now no no I
don't know right now
you mean right now right now no was it
so therefore what you did is you use
your rationality to come to a close
function this logical decision rational
use your rationale yeah I'm conscious
you came to a conscious decision that a
logical decision that I cannot become a
potato
so that was reusing your faculties to
come to a conclusion that's the same way
I'm asking you this question can
something from nothing
it's an impossibility yeah you see the
problem is we don't know because right
now what you're seeing is I said is
there a chance of me being a potato he
said no it's very relevant because we're
doing is you know I can't become a
potato if I thought there is more of a
chance maybe or maybe come in a potato
then something coming from nothing some
become from nothing is an impossibility
because elephants and they make this
epidemic simple can zero ever equal one
like that okay right now I'm gonna
imagine in my head in the future because
you're seeing we will put electrodes in
your head yeah yeah look one
presentation yes good so 0 nor equal in
one is the representation of nothing
cannot make something so therefore
therefore can you show me forgive me
I know this he self admitted that the
nothing is talking about is not nothing
it's actually something you don't can
you please show me where you're claiming
will believe I'm talking with us you're
talking I I think maybe
no you can go and see the only reason
you know okay you said we can go to
youtube and watch it we can go to the
iPhone store no if you allow me I'm
gonna make the connection then I ain't
wasting my time this right now is gonna
prove it
this right now is going to be clear
talking I said do you believe this is
created because you went to the factory
he said no so therefore I said how else
can we prove he said obviously we'll
take it in our hands and we will look
design
design look buddha design this is one
second one second so what you've done is
this you said I don't need to go to the
finish I said we will take it in our
hand and we will see the same exact
design this is there you go yes but if
we can prove that one no look you said I
said you did you go and see the man he
made this he said no once it wasn't did
you see the way it was made allow me
I said that you're gonna see the man who
made this no did you see the man who
decides the way you designed it
no boss it but I said how do you know
but did you I can did you did you I ask
you did you know I saw so they're rubber
allow me to talk there for you believe
this is designed when you haven't seen
the person whom a discussion I'm seeing
the exact double standards this is the
universe is billions and trillions in
this because because this is the this is
Apple and the oranges we compare
something completely different right
this is because of the premise that I
use with the phone you did not see the
one who threw the relevance you did not
see with your eyes the one who made it
but you believe it's made because of
design belly if you did know wasn't it
you said bring me table for but you did
not see God but you reject the universe
contradiction now contradiction no
because content eg you comparing apple
in
because I can show the blue okay yeah
this is this it's okay intelligence
somebody has a brain to do it yeah okay
so the my primacy of my second argument
my premises but no where are you going
with this its Delhi comparing I reject
your premise because I heard about this
because you know I was wrong about what
smuggling your argument is if there is
written by humans that the universe or
space okay and we agree on the premise
that if there is information there has
to be intelligence yeah okay
yeah so now necessary but we can test it
we can go to the printing house we can
we see where when you go to
hieroglyphics we see information and we
went and found the Rosetta Stone and we
deciphered the holidays
therefore we saw that there is
information and then requires
intelligence now DNA a series a single
strand of DNA if you took every book on
this planet and put it together it will
not be equivalent to an information in
one strand of a DNA so this requires
intelligence information in the DNA
information yes
if I say so then the ape can write the
book is intelligent yes yes so therefore
there is information this
if you see the castle made by the ants
it is intelligent Maggie of course this
is a kind of intelligence
nobody's design with so therefore I'm
using this infamous rubber you said you
are here and I gave you the premise this
is the information it requires I can say
many things I am we actually check that
I've given you enough evidence does the
DNA have information because you compare
[Music]